les chéris merci en tout cas d'être avec
nous alors il ya des comédiens
formidables dans l'équipe et ce soir on
aimerait rejouer des scènes de premiers
baisers vous allez nous dire qu'ils sont
pour vous qui est pour vous le meilleur
comédien de tpm paix on en a sélectionné
six il ya un premier duo qui va composé
d'isabelle morini bosc et doc gynéco un
deuxième de jean michel et maxime et un
troisième de mathieu et calais on va
mettre à les remettre
ludivine ah non je n'aime pas non c'est
non mature et ludivine à dakar six
voitures alors on va faire on va
regarder une première scène vous allez
devoir la rejouer akissi d'accord on va
axer l'ex youn et deux premiers couples
qui vont être qualifié ensuite pour la
demi finale
d'accord c'est parti regardez le premier
extrait de premiers baisers
c'était une discussion entre anet et
conçoit rappel de françois c'était ton
mec je me rappelle très bien tu l'a
vraiment pécho lieu ou pas on est tous
barrés en soit est ce que dit la vérité
est ce que tu es ce que tu as dit
j'étais déjà sortis et cadets mettre la
barre au frais en vrai mais non toi tu
as dis à mes choix de match de 1er mai
dès le premier baiser
non non quoi alors de vendredi dont six
comme on verra on en parlera j'ai
l'impression dégâts que ça et ça se
choper beaucoup là bas là que nous nous
n'est que dans les mauvais endroit à 100
est bon on est ici bien sûr mais je
nouvelle émission chroniqueurs on n'a
jamais su non non jamais assez si vous
regardez
[Rires]
de plus par annette faut que je
t'embrasse
attention annette iam the king of the
flipper c'est très bien bravo mais
maintenant tu m'as ce tranquille mais
amère est jeu vient d'écraser jérôme au
flip tu vas pas je suis super ok et
alors c'est pas une raison
on ne refuse jamais un baiser d'accord
tu m'embrasses et que tu laisses
tranquille parce que moi j'ai pas que ça
à fond alors attention on va démarrer
avec mathieu christine alors on y
revient en donnez moi c'est parti pour
ce fait la même si j'ai pas de texte à
tahiti on vient de le voir tu dis permis
à la valeur
tout ça après lui je m'en fous mais tes
mains j'ai de battre jean michel au
flipper c'est vrai ouais mais tu as fais
comment bah je sais pas c'était avec mon
talent qu'est ce que tu fais ce soir pas
pire quel talent ce très bel essai en
bresse moi j'ai préféré embrasser saint
michel
[Rires]
vitu ncaa ou l'autre acteur qui a les
cheveux gris à des séjours fait ces
jeunes c'est lui allait enfin c'est une
catastrophe de zhouqu
mais les deux c'est une capacité le 14
mai la soirée et maxima désigne en irak
revient sur la scène mais je me suis
occupé en ce moment je sais pas ce qui
m'arrive a enchaîné les cours ça
n'arrête pas entre la nuit il laisse par
terre qui te laissera noms qui me
laissent leurs terres elle monte sur moi
et mes deux m'écrase par la même
occasion à changer ton slip top depuis
la semaine dernière et halte à l'euro ce
serait un gros non non j'ai le stream
bleu tu sais que toi et si jamais rien
passé entre ou encore non et pourquoi
pas ce que tu aies jamais proposé quoi
que ce soit je le veux
[Applaudissements]
attention yabou faire attention aux
échos jean et qu issa ça c'est pas du
tout on a beau temps ah oui ça va faire
un sacré bout de temps
et alors il paraît que tu as quelque
chose à midi ouais résilient j'adore se
dégrader de montres tout se dégrade chez
moi rien qu'à et ce col mao col du fémur
échancré je suis allée effectue donc je
suis les 22 août à chemise je suis de
portago une chute qui venait pour une
raison précise c'est ce qu'on a dit oui
je voulais dire un truc à tes lèvres
il enclenche je verrai après si
j'accepte vas-y mais avant moi le baiser
que je t'ai donné l avant moi le baiser
que je t'ai donné ça swinguait mais pas
d'or j'adore je vous le dis anthony et
madison il pour moi les pour moi les
deux couples qualité une option maxime
et gens me et doc gynéco et isabelle je
valide
vous validez ouais bah on a
malheureusement perdu mathieu et
ludivine attention deuxième set
regardez-moi passé au deuxième extrait
regardez cet extrait vous allez devoir
jouer la même scène c'est très simple
c'est une scène de bagarre entre jérôme
et françois regarder les puissants
voisins qui criait nommé c'est pas
bientôt fini ce boucan mais je tomberai
toujours
et tiens giro il faut que je t'explique
ne t'énerve pas bêtement tutu et fois
que j'étais prêté ma chambre et tu me
laissant un désordre incroyable
s'inquiète pas je vais l'arrangé et
m'ont pris ma figure il arrivait de quoi
allez vas-y dit le jeu
et vas-y que je te dise un truc
t'es qu'un petit minable à lunettes
savent mieux que d'être un gars frimeur
alors attention
jean-mi avec maxime
geoffrey lui je pense que maxime doit
faire françois bien sûr janvier dans un
giro mais cela faisait plus de place
attention à ce que vous vous rappelez de
cette histoire à isis partie vous
arrivez vous êtes élève et retour à
l'histoire elle m'a fait chier et tu te
laisses journée à ce que j'ai entendu
dire quoi
eric tuboeuf sur moi quoi joue pas là
mais non non c'est pas moi c'est ça
c'est pas toi non plus chose
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est déjà mieux
attention il a et docks alors je romps
doit verser cet objet déco qui doit
servir en fait françois fait françois
alors attention doc gynéco vallée mais
qu'est ce que tu dis là
alors tu dois tu énervé parce que à la
pala par angers tâche ardue merci maxime
despatie mes jambes mais merci quand
même temps non mais c'est pas grave je
te connais tu viens là m'emmerder
l'enjeu en train de jouer au flipper
c'est que tu as un truc qui me déplaît
alors dirais même pas je te vas dire en
fait non il y avait dans la chambre rien
tout va bien mais je te connais alphonse
tu connais françois marguerin quand il
vient comme ça c'est que tu as un truc
de travers alors ça va durer deux
déplacements récurrents le faire mais
google crève l'abcès
mais crève l'abcès m iams r non
[Rires]
alors merci à isabelle et docks
alors franchement annette vous appelle
année alors anthony magali et anthony a
eu magali vous dites quoi bah écoute là
quand même
c'est l'agent c'est incroyable et mac et
pour moi jamie est le meilleur comédien
comme journée d'accord
si j'arrive à gagner
[Applaudissements]